Tom and I have known each other for a
while obviously and he always gets me to
do anything he wants me to do actually
he's like I want to present it to
student award thing for the Academy I'm
like okay I'm gonna see a lot of you
know films with people's parents in it
or something you know I thought I was
gonna be but I did I thought I was gonna
be like I'm gonna be a great night up
put some jeans I'll come down this is
blowing me away man I mean this is
there's real talent in the room and now
I realize it's an opportunity to grease
up some of my future employers I didn't
say nothin funny i'm serious you writing
down names write down names thank you
i'm very honored to be here to present
the awards for a film genre that I have
a great deal of respect for here are
tonight's awards for outstanding
achievement and documentary filmmaking
our bronze medal winner was made at a
school that is a first-time winner in
the Student Academy Awards created at
the Art Institute of jacksonville in
florida by filmmaker heather berkey lost
country is a story of Cuba and Castro as
told to the eyes of three Cuban
expatriates I will hire you any day of
the week one down one down
for sure I'll work for free to have him
on my ok ok I would like to thank the
academy for recognizing my film and
giving me this wonderful gift that no
one can ever take away from me mr. Tom's
rack I wanted to say thanks to Julio
Maxim Eduardo the three men that were in
my film for sharing their stories with
me and allowing me to share them with
the world they opened up their homes and
their hearts to me and I'm very very
grateful to them I'm going to thank all
my professors two of them that are here
tonight audience stuff and everyone else
at the Art Institute it's very small
school and they took me who was a mom of
three that knew nothing about filmmaking
and in three years turned me into an
Academy Award winner some very very
grateful to all of them thank you to all
my family and friends who have loved and
supported me and to my fine foxy ladies
that are in the audience tonight that
came out here all the way from
Jacksonville I especially want to thank
much three children Eric Ella and
Addison for being so patient with mommy
why she was working on this and for
seeing them to play video games while i
was editing i love all of you so much
all the way to pluto and back even
though yes L I know Pluto's not a planet
anymore to my fiancé Greg I would have
never been able to get this far without
you and I'm very happy you're here to
share it with me I don't think I can
ever repay you but I'll spend the rest
of my life trying one of the nicest
things someone said to me when I went to
Miami to show Julio maxon had water and
they had 50 of their close friends and
family which anyone knows the Cubans
that's like a small amount of their
close games from Himalayan friends and
his older Cuban lady I came over during
that time she came up to me and I didn't
know her and I'd have been introduced to
her and she laid her hand
my shoulder and she was just looked at
me and she was so sincere and she said I
just want you to know that you have
lived many lives before this and you
have a very old soul and this is what
you were born to do and I didn't know
what to say I was speechless but for
somebody to tell you this is what you
were born to do that's you know it's an
amazing thing and i know that i was born
to tell stories and however i can tell
stories that's what i want to do for the
rest of my life and you know i'm very
grateful that the Academy has given me
this one step in my career that
hopefully will open many doors and allow
me to do that and you know every girl
and woman wants to feel beautiful and
successful and strong and special and
tonight I feel all of those things so
thank you very very much